Olá tudo bem Hoje eu vou falar de
algumas comidas que t o poder especial
de ajudar a manter nossas artérias
limpas e saudáveis não vou dizer apenas
de quatro Alimentos mas sim pratos
completos ou receitas com sinergia de
ingredientes que são fantásticos para
manter as nossas artérias flexíveis e
limpas aqui o Dr Alan Dutra médico há
mais de 25 anos e eu vou compartilhar
com vocês algumas das dicas valiosas de
alimentação que podem fazer toda a
diferença na sua saúde
cardiovascular pessoal sabe quando a
gente ouve falar sobre artérias
entupidas ou endurecimento das artérias
isso é a aterosclerose que acontece
quando temos muito acúmulo de placas nas
paredes das artérias essas placas podem
ser formadas por cálcio gordura e
proteínas quando existe a formação
dessas placas as artérias ficam
estreitas e o fluxo de sangue para o
coração e outras partes do corpo diminui
e não é só um probleminha localizado não
pode afetar grande parte do nosso
sistema circulatório incluindo as
artérias carótidas que são super
importantes porque levam oxigênio e
nutrientes para o nosso cérebro quando
essas artérias começam a entupir os
riscos de isquemia cerebral e AVC batem
a porta e quais são os vilões dessa
história quando falamos entupimento ou
enfraquecimento das paredes arteriais
que podem levar o acúmulo dessas placas
existem alguns fatores de risco
importantes principais que precisamos
ficar de olho o primeiro grande Alerta é
a resistência à insulina e o Diabetes
incluindo pré-diabetes essas condições
são sem dúvida as maiores causas de
problema nas artérias por isso é crucial
ter um controle e um olhar especial para
esses fatores o stress também joga
contra a saúde do nosso sistema
circulatório assim como a pressão alta e
o tabagismo e claro não podemos esquecer
dos triglicerídeos elevados e do
colesterol alterado mas aqui estamos
falando especificamente do colesterol
LDL oxidado não do colesterol Total esse
tipo de colesterol quando oxidado é
particularmente danoso as artérias além
disso a obesidade é um fator que engloba
e potencializa todos esses problemas
assim como sedentarismo e uma dieta não
saudável uma alimentação rica em
produtos Ultra processados frituras
grãos refinados carboidratos simples e
açúcares é uma receita certa para
danificar as artérias pessoal então
vamos a primeira comida que são os
peixes ricos em ômega-3 como o salmão a
sardinha e a cavala esses peixes não só
nos oferecem uma excelente fonte de
proteína mas também trazem um tesouro de
ômega3 com Epa e DH em altas doses
essenciais para manter nossas artérias
saudáveis e flexíveis
ômega-3 é vital paraa saúde das artérias
por ser um ácido gracho que atua
diretamente no combate a inflamação um
dos principais fatores na formação de
placas ateroscleróticas ele ajuda a
melhorar a função endotelial que é a
camada que reveste interiormente os
vasos sanguíneos e linfáticos reduzir a
inflamação e diminuir a formação de
trombos contribuindo pra prevenção de
doenças vasculares como a aterosclerose
e sim o preço pode ser um impecvel para
muitos mas a sardinha É uma opção mais
acessível e igualmente nutritiva pessoal
vamos temperar esse peixe com temperos
que fazem toda a diferença começando
pelo áo e Graças aos seus antioxidantes
protege as células e ajuda a dilatar os
vasos e não podemos esquecer da cúrcuma
ou açafrão com suas propriedades
anti-inflamatórias Poderosas que trata A
inflamação crônica um fator de risco
para muitas doenças cardíacas isso
porque a curcumina que é o mais poderoso
composto dentro da cúrcuma ele exerce um
papel signif ativo na redução do dano
endotelial diminuindo o enrijecimento da
sua parede isso é um processo chave no
combate da aterosclerose depois você vai
adicionar um toque Generoso de coentro
que não só traz frescor e Sabor único
aos pratos mas também pode ajudar na
detoxificação de metais pesados Graças
às suas propriedades quelantes pessoal
para finalizar após fazer o peixe seja
grelhado cozido ou assado vem o toque
final que dá Sabor e faz uma boa
diferença Não há dúvida de que o limão
tem o maior benefício paraa saúde de
qualquer fruta do planeta quando se
trata de ajudar na prevenção e até no
tratamento das artérias obstruídas além
de ser incrivelmente versátil na
culinária O limão é um campeão e
vitamina C essencial para a saúde das
artérias ele também contém ácido cítrico
que ajuda a diminuir os depósitos de
placa de cálcio nas artérias fazendo
dele um aliado e tanto na proteção
cardiovascular partindo para a nossa
segunda escolha de comida saudável para
as artérias vamos falar sobre uma bela
salada mas não qualquer salada estamos
Mirando nas Folhas Verdes escuras Então
por que essas folhas são tão especiais
primeiramente elas são ricas em vitamina
C e vitamina K ambas essenciais
para a manutenção da saúde arterial a
vitamina C ajuda a proteger as artérias
contra os danos dos radicais livres
enquanto a vitamina K é fundamental
paraa coagulação do sangue Além disso
essas folhas são carregadas de folato
que é a vitamina B9 parte do Complexo B
e que é vital para prevenir danos que
podem levar a doenças cardiovasculares
pessoal magnésio das Folhas Verdes
escuras é crucial pra saúde óssea e para
a promoção de um coração saudável
prevenindo a formação de coágulos
sanguíneos e o potássio ajuda a
controlar e regular a pressão arterial e
a prevenir doenças cardíacas ao
facilitar a circulação do sangue e
relaxar as artérias para a salada as
minhas folhas favoritas são agrião
rúcula almeirão mostarda e or pronobis A
ideia é variar você pode preparar uma
salada mista com várias dessas as folhas
ou alternar o consumo delas ao longo da
semana o importante é garantir uma boa
porção dessas saladas na sua dieta
diária para temperar além do Limão cujos
benefícios já mencionei não esqueça do
azeite de oliva O Azeite é um
ingrediente chave para manter as
artérias saudáveis porque tem
propriedades antioxidantes e ajuda na
redução do colesterol LDL oxidado no
entanto é importante escolher um azeite
de oliva de boa qualidade Infelizmente o
preço do azeite de oliva aumentou muito
nesses tempos e muitos produtos no
mercado não são puros sendo misturados
com outros óleos vegetais ruins por isso
eu recomendo assistir ao meu vídeo sobre
como escolher um azeite de qualidade
pessoal se tem um investimento que vale
a pena fazer muito mais impactante para
sua saúde do que qualquer super alimento
caro da moda e optar por um azeite de
oliva de excelente qualidade mesmo que
isso signifique ajustar outras partes da
sua dieta Como substituir o salmão pela
sardinha por exemplo o azeite de oliva
de qualidade é uma escolha cara mas
sábia paraa saúde do seu coração a
combinação de azeite com Folhas Verdes
escuras é uma forma inteligente de
absorver ao máximo os nutrientes desses
vegetais alguns dos fitonutrientes
Presentes nas folhas são solúveis em
gordura O que significa que o azeite de
oliva pode ajudar a extrair esses
nutrientes importantes durante a
digestão você pode in cimentar a salada
com outras opções saudáveis mas isso que
eu falei é básico para ajudar suas
artérias prosseguindo com as comidas
chegamos a terceira sugestão as frutas
dentro essa seleção criteriosa algumas
frutas se destacam os seus benefícios
específicos à paredes das artérias as
frutas vermelhas o limão a melancia
abacate são minhas recomendações de ouro
na melancia encontramos a citrulina que
é um aminoácido que desempenha um papel
na produção do óxido nítrico no corpo o
óxido nítrico é vital para as artérias
por vários motivos ele ajuda a relaxar
os vasos sanguíneos melhorando o fluxo
sanguíneo e reduzindo a pressão arterial
e também tem efeitos antioxidantes e
antiinflamatórios que protegem contra o
acúmulo de placas e outras formas de de
doenças
cardiovasculares curiosamente a parte
branca da Melancia aquela que
frequentemente descartamos é
particularmente rica em citrulina
passando para abacate ela é repleto de
gorduras saudáveis especialmente o áo
leico conhecido por seus benefícios à
saúde cardiovascular essas gorduras
saudáveis ajudam a manter os níveis de
colesterol em equilíbrio além de
aumentar o HDL o dito colesterol bom
além disso o abacate é rico em potássio
e antioxidantes com a vitamina E que
protegem as células sanguíneas contra os
danos oxidativos pessoal eu entendo que
as frutas vermelhas são fantásticas e
repletas de antioxidantes sei que elas
podem ser um pouco mais caras mas
alternativas um pouco mais econômicas
como optar por versões congeladas estas
podem ser adquiridas em embalagens
maiores de um ou 2 kg o que acaba sendo
mais acessível financeiramente do que as
frutas frescas claro sempre prefira
escolher por frutas frescas e orgânicas
quando for possível mas sabemos que nem
sempre isso é viável para todos o
importante é incorporar essas frutas na
sua alimentação evitando substituí-las
por produtos
ultraprocessados entendo a preocupação
com os agrotóxicos que realmente são um
problema e se a compra de frutas
orgânicas não se ajusta no seu orçamento
consuma as versões convencionais
aplicando técnicas para reduzir a
presença de resíduos de pesticidas Eu
tenho um vídeo onde eu compartilho
algumas dicas eficazes para diminuir a
contaminação por agrotóxicos como deixar
as frutas de molho em soluções
específicas o que pode tornar o consumo
mais seguro e saudável se você tem a
possibilidade de optar por orgânicos
ótimo Maravilha caso contrário não deixe
de incluir esses alimentos vitais na sua
dieta pessoal agora vamos falar sobre um
tema recorrente nos meus vídeos os
alimentos fermentados a fermentação é um
processo fascinante não só transforma o
sabor dos alimentos mas também tem um
papel crucial em diminuir os
antinutrientes aquelas toxinas que as
plantas usam como defesa contra pragas e
predadores e que podem em excesso serem
problemáticas paraa nossa saúde Isso já
é um ponto superpositivo Além do mais ao
fermentar alimentos especialmente
vegetais as bactérias envolvidas no
processo produzem vitamina K2 que é
essencial para a saúde arterial a
vitamina K2 é a principal vitamina que
ajuda a manter o cálcio fora das
artérias ela é necessária para ativar
proteína que ajudam a direcionar o caos
para os ossos e impedir que ele se
acumule em tecidos moles como nas
artérias dependendo do alimento
fermentado podemos ter também um aumento
bem bacana na disponibilidade de
vitamina C que é crucial para o
fortalecimento das artérias entre os
meus alimentos fermentados favoritos
estão O chucrut que é o mais barato de
todos para você fazer o kinshi Nat missô
e temp pessoal o kinshi por exemplo é um
alimento fermentado coreano à base de
vegetais que pode ser bastante picante
mas existem receitas Mais suaves
disponíveis na internet Além disso
alimentos como picles e alho também
podem ser fermentados em casa oferecendo
não só sabores deliciosos mas também
muitos benefícios à saúde espero que
essa conversa tenha esclarecido algumas
dúvidas e quem sabe te inspirado a
cuidar da sua saúde
cardiovascular Muito obrigado pela sua
atenção um grande abraço um beijo no seu
coração e você é
fera